It is easy to forget that a country so rich
in History like Italy, is – as a Nation
– younger that the US.
Italy as we know it today became a unified
State only in 1861, following decades of struggle.
At the forefront of many of those fights,
you would be sure to find today’s protagonist,
General Giuseppe Garibaldi.
[click on link for pronunciation]
General Garibaldi cut a distinctive figure
amongst the protagonists of that epic novel
that is European history of the XIX century,
when Nations were forged in iron, blood, but
also in gold and deception.
With his enviable beard, his Tuscan cigars,
Argentine ponchos, his trusty saber and six-shooter,
Garibaldi had become one of the most popular
men in the World.
So much so that his men accepted his autographed
photos as a salary!
Today we are going to look at his revolutionary
and military career, especially at this most
famous ‘Expedition of the Thousand’ which
led to the unification of Italy.
This is also the story of a natural born soldier,
and a natural leader of soldiers who became
a General with little formal training, only
direct experience of fighting.
To put it in his own words:
“The use of the sword I learnt by defending
my own head …
… and in giving my best endeavours to split
those of others!”
The Young Italy
Giuseppe Garibaldi was born on the 4th of
July 1807 in Nice, now in France, but back
then part of the Kingdom of Piedmont-Sardinia.
This was one of the many States in which the
Italian peninsula had been divided into for
centuries.
North Eastern Italy was part of the Austrian
Empire, which also controlled indirectly other
smaller Duchies from Tuscany to the Adriatic
coast.
Central Italy was part of the State of the
Church, ruled by the Pope, and the South was
ruled by the Bourbon dynasty, tied both to
Austria and Spain.
Young Giuseppe’s family lived off the sea:
they were fishermen and coastal traders.
Garibaldi also had close ties with the sea,
spending most of his spare time swimming and
sailing.
He enlisted as a merchant sailor at a very
young age and sailed across the Mediterranean
and the Black Sea.
It was during a voyage to Russia that he became
acquainted with some members of the Young
Italy movement.
The Young Italy was a revolutionary organisation,
with ties to secret societies, led by Republican
activist Giuseppe Mazzini [Click link for
pronunciation].
Mazzini had instigated or participated in
many attempts to overthrow the rulers of the
Italian governments and was now living in
exile in London.
Garibaldi was fascinated with Mazzini’s
ideals and pledged allegiance to the Young
Italy and their affiliated secret organisation,
the ‘Carbonari’[pronunciation].
The aim of these societies was to unify the
Italian people under a single democratic republican
Government.
In 1833, Garibaldi enlisted as an officer
in the Navy of Piedmont-Sardinia.
The following year, instructed by Mazzini,
he instigated a mutiny, intended to spark
a wider revolution and install a Republic
in Piedmont.
The plan failed miserably.
He barely escaped capture, crossed the border
with France and hid in Marseille for some
time.
Yet, according to rumours, on the day he left
he found the time to make love to three different
women.
Which may be true.
Or may be an early indication that he was
very good at propping up his own image.
South American Adventures
Physical prowess aside, young Garibaldi had
a thirst for adventure.
In 1836 he set sail for South America, and
like a Che Guevara one century earlier, he
looked for libertarian causes he could serve.
He found one in Brazil, where he joined the
separatist republic of Rio Grande do Sul.
How did he serve their cause?
As a pirate!
Or a corsair more precisely: his job was to
prey on Brazilian shipping to harass their
supply lines and support the Republic.
During these adventures he fell in love with
a married woman, Anna Maria Ribeiro da Silva,
better known as Anita, who would remain by
his side even in battle.
The war with Brazil was doomed to fail and
Garibaldi was discharged from Rio Grande in
1840.
He was compensated for his services with a
herd of cattle, which he drove to Montevideo,
Uruguay, with Anita and their son Menotti.
In 1842 he joined another war of liberation:
that of Uruguay against Juan Manuel de Rosas,
the dictator of Argentina.
Initially he was put in charge of the Uruguayan
navy, but in 1843 Garibaldi took command of
a newly formed Italian Legion, composed of
exiles and libertarians like him.
Looking for cheap cloth for their uniforms,
he stumbled upon a bargain: red shirts, used
by abattoir workers.
From then on, his troops would wear the distinctive
tunics and would be known as Redshirts.
Garibaldi’s fame grew, not only in the Americas,
but also in Europe.
This was cemented by the victories he achieved
in 1846, most notably at the Battle of Sant’Antonio.
In this engagement he first adopted his trademark
tactic: he would establish a defensive line,
absorb the impact of the enemy’s frontal
attack and then outmanoeuvre it by launching
a surprise counter-attack on its flanks, often
by means of a bayonet charge.
His South American experiences gave him invaluable
training in the techniques of guerrilla warfare
that he would later use against traditional
European armies.
He had now acquired the reputation of a professional
rebel, an indomitable activist for the causes
of independence and republican rule.
Back to Italy
In April of 1848, Garibaldi, Anita and their
children sailed back to Italy on a ship called
‘Speranza’[pronunciation]
Or ‘Hope’ in Italian.
Mazzini had invited him to return to Europe
to join another war.
A popular revolt had ousted the Austrians
from Milan.
The King of Piedmont, Charles-Albert, had
taken the occasion to declare war on Austria
to aid the Italian rebels.
This was the First War of Italian Independence.
Mazzini saw the occasion to ‘infiltrate’
the struggle to further his Republican agenda.
Garibaldi entered the fight against the Austrians
with a force of irregular volunteers: despite
his victories, the Piedmontese army had been
defeated at Custoza and signed an armistice.
Outnumbered, Garibaldi dissolved his units
and evaded capture by the Austrians by escaping
to Switzerland.
The opportunity for another fight presented
itself at the end of 1848, in Rome.
Pope Pious IX had gained fame as a rather
liberal ruler, giving hope to Italian patriots
that he may be willing to lead a federation
of Italian states under him.
But in 1848 he revoked any liberal reform
he had instituted in the State of the Church.
Mazzini and the Young Italy then staged a
revolt which drove the Pope from Rome and
installed a Republic.
In February 1849 Garibaldi had joined the
Roman Republic and was ready to defend it
by any means.
In April 1849, newly elected French President
Louis Napoleon (later Napoleon III), sent
an army to Rome to restore order, as a means
to gain the favour of the Catholic electorate.
A contingent under General Picard attempted
to seize the Janiculum hill.
They were expecting to be welcomed with open
arms by the God-fearing Romans.
Instead, they found Garibaldi.
The General put up a stiff resistance, stalling
the advance of Picard.
And then, he replicated his tactic of Sant’Antonio.
The French were taken by surprise and retreated
hastily, leaving almost 300 dead and prisoners
behind.
In May he defeated an army sent by the King
of Naples, and in June he was leading the
defense of Rome against another French siege.
But there was no chance of holding the city,
and the republic collapsed.
In July of 1849 Garibaldi and Anita were on
the run from the French and the Austrians.
While in hiding, Anita contracted malaria
and died in Giuseppe’s arms.
He barely had the time to mourn her, when
he had to go into exile again.
This time Garibaldi first fled to Tangiers,
then New York, where for a time worked in
a candle factory with Antonio Meucci [pronunciation],
arguably the inventor of the telephone.
In 1852 and 1853, Garibaldi had returned to
a life of sailing: he was now a merchant ship
captain, transporting guano – i.e. bird
or bat excrement – from Peru to China.
Only in 1854 he was allowed to return to Italy.
Having collected a family inheritance Garibaldi
was able to buy part of the small island of
Caprera, off the Sardinian coast, which remained
his home for the rest of his life.
Call of War
It was the 2nd of March 1859 and Garibaldi
was milking a cow in his Caprera farm when
he received a surprise visitor: a Piedmontese
officer, envoy of Prime Minister Camillo Benso,
Count of Cavour.
[Camillo Benso]
[Cavour]
Cavour was a skilled politician who had been
engineering big plans for the Kingdom of Piedmont.
When the War of Crimea broke out in October
1853, he had convinced the King Victor Emmanuel
II to join the allied side against the Russian
Empire.
Cavour’s only interest was to have a seat
at the peace negotiations, in March 1856.
Cavour took the occasion to approach Napoleon
III and bring to his attention the plight
of Italian citizens under the rule of the
Austrians and their allies.
He completed his seduction of Napoleon III
with the help of his own cousin, the countess
Virginia of Castiglione, who actually, physically
seduced the lusty French Emperor, drawing
him closer to the Italian cause.
[Virginia as in the American State.
Ca - steel -ee -awe - ne.
Ca as in Car, Ne as in Ned]
Napoleon III and Victor Emmanuel II signed
a secret treaty, by which France committed
to intervene in a war against the Austrians,
should they attack Piedmont.
Cavour was preparing a trap to lure Austria
into war and thought he could make good use
of Garibaldi.
Following the envoy, Garibaldi met Victor
Emmanuel II in Turin.
These two were polar opposites ideologically,
but they immediately clicked, bonding over
their shared love of hunting, combat and women.
The King offered Garibaldi a formal commission
as General in the Piedmontese army, in charge
of the “Hunters of the Alps”, a voluntary
corps specialised in mountain warfare.
Now, Garibaldi, Cavour and the King may have
had common enemies, nut not common goals.
Garibaldi’s aim was the unification of Italy
– if possible a Republican Italy.
Cavour’s plans were to extend the territory
and power of Piedmont and the ruling house
of Savoy.
In the first months of 1859 Cavour set the
stage: he started amassing troops on the border
with the Austrian empire.
And he encouraged Italians under Austrian
rule to flee to Piedmont where they would
join Garibaldi’s Hunters.
On the 23rd of April, the Austrians fell into
the trap: they issued an ultimatum for de-mobilisation,
which was refused.
The Second War of Italian Independence was
declared and the joint Franco-Piedmontese
forces sprang into action.
Garibaldi and his 3000 volunteers were outnumbered
and outgunned, but he managed to score important
victories in the Lombard Alps.
In May he defeated a larger force at the Battle
of Varese, by using his signature tactic.
Over the following weeks he captured the cities
of Como, [Brescia] and [Bergamo].
By July, he was about to march into the [Trentino]
region, when he received urgent orders to
halt the advance, and to return to Turin.
Unbeknownst to him, on the 11th of July Napoleon
III had agreed a secret armistice with Austrian
Emperor Franz Josef.
Horrified by the huge loss of life at the
Battle of [Solferino], the French Emperor
wanted to cease hostilities.
When the Piedmontese were informed, they had
no choice but to stop fighting, as the Austrians
would outnumber them more than 2 to 1.
The outcome of the war was positive to the
King and Cavour: they had expanded into Lombardy,
annexing Milan and other important industrial
areas.
At the same time, they had annexed other smaller
independent states in the North.
The Kingdom of Piedmont now controlled roughly
one third of Italian territory.
On the other hand, Garibaldi was deeply disappointed:
not only because of the secret armistice.
He had also found out that as compensation
for the French intervention, Cavour had ceded
the city of Nice to Napoleon III.
Paradoxically, the hometown of the champion
of Italian unification was now part of France.
The Expedition of the Thousand
Garibaldi had a further disappointment in
January of 1860, on a more personal level.
On the 24th he married his young fiancée,
Countess [Giuseppina] [Raimondi].
Immediately after the ceremony, the General
received a mysterious note.
Upon reading it, he snarled at the bride:
“I thought I had married a Countess, not
a whore!”
Apparently Giuseppina had been seeing other,
younger men, in the past months and was in
fact five months pregnant.
Garibaldi had the marriage immediately annulled.
The General returned once more to his beloved
Caprera to lick his wounds, but news from
Sicily would lead him to unsheathe his sabre
once more.
In April 1860 a revolt broke out in Palermo.
The Southern half of the Italian peninsula
was ruled by King Francis II of the house
of Bourbon, with ties to Austria and Spain.
The Bourbons had a history of repressing revolutionary
outbreaks, especially in Sicily.
They succeeded also in this occasion, but
the revolt had inspired Garibaldi to do the
unthinkable.
He raised a volunteer force with plans to
invade Sicily, cross the Messina straits to
the mainland and fight his way ‘up the boot’,
conquering Naples and perhaps even Rome.
This would mean finally unifying Italy into
a single state.
At this stage he had realised that a Republican
Italy was a far-fetched dream and was content
with it being a monarchy under Victor Emmanuel
II.
On the night between the 5th and 6th of May
General Garibaldi launched the Expedition
of the Thousand, which would cement his status
as a legendary icon in Europe and America.
With a force of roughly 1000 volunteers, aged
11 to 69, Garibaldi ‘borrowed’ two steamers
and set sail for Sicily.
The official version of the story goes that
Victor Emmanuel II and Cavour, who outwardly
condemned this adventure, secretly hoped for
it to succeed.
In reality, Cavour did something more than
just hope.
The Mastermind from Turin had arranged for
some Piedmontese officers and soldiers to
join the Thousands.
Officially, they were deserters, but this
was just a ploy to sustain plausible deniability.
He then arranged for a garrison commander
in Tuscany to provide Garibaldi with weapons
and ammunition.
Again, the official version was that these
were stolen.
Oh, and the requisitioned steamers?
They were also a covert donation from the
Piedmontese government.
Cavour had also arranged secret meetings with
British Freemasons, as a conduit to secure
London’s approval and support of the whole
operation.
The British Empire had an economic interest
in causing the demise of the Bourbon Kingdom:
gaining control of the sulphur mines in Sicily.
On the 11th of May 1860, Garibaldi and his
Thousand landed in Marsala, western Sicily.
The harbour defences responded with a weak
bombardment.
This was to avoid harming the two neutral
British vessels which “by total coincidence”
were in the port to stock up on Marsala wine.
On the 15th of May Garibaldi’s redshirts
had their first pitch battle against the Neapolitan
troops, in [Calatafimi].
The Bourbons had gained the upper ground and
the Thousand had to fight an uphill struggle,
literally, with no artillery or cavalry support.
Garibaldi’s second in command, [Nino Bixio],
suggested a retreat.
To which the General replied:
“Today either we make Italy, or we die!”
And was immediately hit by a rock.
That did not kill his moment, though.
Garibaldi interpreted this as the Neapolitans
being out of ammo!
So he charged headlong up the Calatafimi hill,
followed by his men.
The enemies were routed and the Thousand soon
became Thousands, as Sicilian volunteers joined
their ranks.
On the 20th of June the redshirts conquered
Palermo.
Alexandre Dumas, writer of “The Three Musketeers”
at this point joined the Thousand!
He would later co-author and edit the General’s
autobiography.
By mid-July the last Neapolitan Division in
Sicily was preparing for a siege in [Messina],
opposite the ‘tip of the boot’.
As Garibaldi approached the city, the Bourbon
commander sent a detachment of 2500 men to
block his way in the fortified town of [Milazzo].
Things got sticky, as the enemy commander
played a “Garibaldi” on Garibaldi.
That his: he stalled the attack with well-placed
sniper and artillery fire from behind the
walls of Milazzo, and then launched a sudden
flanking counterattack – but with cavalry.
The cavalry charge surrounded Garibaldi and
his staff and almost succeeded in capturing
him, but the General, saber drawn, cut and
slashed his way out of the encirclement.
Milazzo and Messina fell, and by August the
redshirts had reached the mainland.
As they marched upwards, Neapolitan resistance
melted away, marred by poor morale and possibly
by Cavour’s tactic of bribing some of their
generals.
On the 1st of October the Bourbons staged
their last resistance with the Battle of the
Volturno river, the largest of Garibaldi’s
career.
[Vole - tour - no]
Also in this occasion he risked capture or
death, as his carriage was riddled with gunfire
by a Neapolitan patrol.
Also in this occasion the General drew his
saber and hacked at the assailants, before
re-joining the main battle.
The battle was another victory for the redshirts.
In the meanwhile, the Piedmontese army had
descended from the North, conquering the Eastern
side of the State of Church in central Italy.
On the 15th of October, the Piedmontese Army,
led by Victor Emmanuel himself, met with Garibaldi’s
forces in a town called [Teano].
This was Cavour’s idea of course: the plan
was to join up Garibaldi’s conquests with
Northern Italy to achieve unification.
And at the same time, prevent Garibaldi from
attacking Rome, and the French garrison still
protecting the Pope.
Cavour was expecting a violent clash, but
it took only a veiled threat from the King
to avoid that:
“Your troops are tired, General.
Mine are fresh.
It is my turn now.”
And Garibaldi handed over his conquests to
the King.
On the 17th of March 1861 the Kingdom of Italy
was finally declared.
The unification was not an easy process: some
Southern Italians did not take kindly to the
“Piedmont-isation”
Of their lands and launched a 10 year civil
war, which was for decades covered up as a
series of large scale police operations against
bandits or brigands.
But that’s another story.
Back to November 1860 - on the 9th Garibaldi
set sail for Caprera once again.
As his vessel exited the harbour, British
warships fired a salvo in salute to the man
who had risked more than anyone to unify Italy.
The guns of the Piedmontese fleet remained
silent.
The Ageing General
Giuseppe Garibaldi resumed a simple life in
his beloved Caprera.
Like Cincinnatus, the ancient Roman general,
he was content with a few simple supplies
as a reward: stockfish, seeds, and a large
box of pasta.
His exploits in Southern Italy did not go
unnoticed in the US.
On the 3rd of December 1860, abolitionist
Frederick Douglass declared in a speech that,
should the South secede:
“I believe a Garibaldi would arise who would
march into those States with a thousand men,
and summon to his standard sixty thousand,
if necessary, to accomplish the freedom of
the slave.”
This may have been an inspiration for Abrahm
Lincoln, who in July 1861, offered General
Garibaldi a commission in the Union Army.
It has been evaluated that his aggressive
tactics may have led to a quicker end to the
Civil War, but of course this did not happen.
Garibaldi was keen to accept, on the condition
that the abolition of slavery was formalised
as key war aim for the Union.
Even if Lincoln agreed in principle, he was
not ready at that stage to make such a declaration
and Garibaldi eventually declined.
Aged 55, riddled with old wounds and rheumatism,
the General still had some fight left within.
In 1862 he assembled another army to capture
Rome, but he was stopped by the regular Italian
Army.
Garibaldi ordered his men not to shoot against
fellow Italians, but a skirmish ensued and
he was shot in the foot.
The defeat did not dent his popularity.
In fact, in April 1864 he visited London,
where he was welcomed triumphantly.
A journalist at the time wrote
“Respect for truth renders it necessary
to say that the female portion of those present
were even more eager than their male companions
to reach Garibaldi”
How Victorian.
In 1866, the young Kingdom of Italy sided
with Prussia against Austria in what was called
the 6 weeks war, aka the Third War of Italian
Independence.
Despite the embarrassment of the 1862 debacle,
Garibaldi agreed to take charge again of the
Hunters of the Alps.
The Italian Army made little progress on land
losing at Custoza, while its Navy suffered
a crushing defeat at Lissa.
Only the Prussian allies and the Hunters scored
victories on the Austrians.
In a repeat of the previous war of independence,
Garibaldi’s men were about to seize Trentino,
when he received an order to halt.
The Austrians had signed an armistice and
handed over the Venetia region.
The General replied to the order with a single
word telegram:
“Obbedisco”
“I obey”
Trentino would be contested for 50 years and
was annexed by Italy only after WWI.
The following year, now 60, Garibaldi clearly
thought some more fighting would do good to
his aching joints.
His target?
Rome again!
This time the Italian army did not manage
to intercept him, but he and his men clashed
with the French near Rome.
The French Army was equipped with the new
Chassepots rifles: these guaranteed a much
higher rate of fire and quicker reload, making
the bayonet charges of the redshirts futile.
The expedition was a disaster.
Once again Garibaldi retreated to his Island.
It looked as though he would retire … but
1870 brought along another occasion for a
righteous fight.
Towards the end of the Franco-Prussian war,
Napoleon III’s rule had collapsed and the
Empire had been replaced by the Paris Commune
and the so called III Republic.
With no ill will against the French, the old
General would fight alongside the young Republic.
He corralled an army of volunteers and engaged
the Prussians in the Vosges region.
Amidst the catastrophe of the Franco-Prussian
war, the Army of the Vosges was one of the
few French units capable of scoring victories
against the invaders, but it was too little,
too late.
The French defeat had a silver lining for
the Italians.
In September of 1870 the garrison protecting
Rome was recalled back to serve in France.
Taking advantage, Italian troops easily marched
into the Eternal City.
Save for Trentino and the region of Trieste,
Italy as we know it today was finally unified.
Legacy
After years of battles, adventures, victories
and defeats, General Garibaldi had finally
settled.
He spent his retirement years in Caprera,
tending to his land.
He received tons of fan mail.
Although it was not stamped, so he had to
pay hundreds of liras in fines!
In 1880 he married for the third time, with
Francesca Armosino.
In his last years Garibaldi founded the “League
of Democracy” which advocated universal
suffrage, female emancipation, the abolition
of ecclesiastical property and a standing
army for national unity.
He also voiced his support for the creation
of a European federation, which would be led
in the future by a greater Germany.
Garibaldi died on 2 June 1882, at the age
of 75.
He wished to have a simple cremation, though
he was buried by his farm on the island of
Caprera.
Giuseppe Garibaldi is nowadays regarded by
most Italians – and non-Italians – as
a selfless hero, a brilliant military leader,
the true driving force behind the unification
of Italy, as well as many other liberal causes.
However all heroes are men and no man is without
blemish.
Some revisionist historians argue that his
exploits in Southern Italy were just a colonial
war disguised by lofty ideals.
Garibaldi had in fact promised a land reform
to the Sicilian peasants, but did not act
on it.
Instead he had ordered a violent repression
of a peasant revolt, to protect British interests.
At best, he had been an unwitting puppet in
the hands of Cavour, the British and the Freemasons,
one who had caused the destruction of the
South and the violence of the 1861-1871 civil
war.
Other sources claim that in the years spent
sailing the Pacific, he had let go of his
ideals, participating in the trade of Chinese
slaves for the guano industry.
According to this version, this is how he
raised the funds to purchase Caprera, not
through an inheritance.
The truth, as in many cases, is open to interpretation.
And even 150 years after the events, politics
can influence the way facts are interpreted.
But whatever the truth, or lack of truth,
Garibaldi’s achievements are undeniable:
this is a man who fought and risked his life
well into his sixties, a man who allowed progressive
ideals to flourish, a man who united a Country.